hello everyone welcome back to the
collider Studio at San Diego Comic-Con
2023 I'm doing one of my absolute
favorite things right now I am talking
horror first of all because it lives
inside is a great movie but the other
thing that makes me really happy to talk
about that movie and bishall right here
is the fact that is your first feature
is it is a miracle to make any movie but
in particular when someone gets a first
feature off the ground I'm like we need
to we need to stop and celebrate that
achievement thank you so much thank you
it was a crazy experience making this
movie I mean I am lucky enough to have
had great
collaborators and partners through the
whole process I mean I our my partners
at QC entertainment came on board when
it was just an idea and then six months
later I had written a script and they
called weirdly enough on like the same
day that I was finished and they were
instantly on board and and you know
these guys are they kind of pioneered
this this form of cultural Horror in
mainstream storytelling obviously it's
been done in the history of horror in
such beautiful ways but get out was such
a checkpoint movie in this in the
sub-genre and so working with these guys
from the beginning and the neon
um who have really kind of changed the
landscape as far as films about other
cultures being in the American Zeitgeist
and so that that partnership from the
beginning it was just unbelievable to
have that through the entire process I'm
coming back to both of those companies
in a minute but just so our audience
gets to know you a little more and your
love of genre so I was reading that when
you moved to North America you were you
were consuming a lot of harm movies and
you found a lot of them quite
influential many questions about that
first I want to know what is the very
first horror movie you ever saw that
that like terrified you that kept you up
at night okay this is going to be a
little controversial a lot of people
don't think it's a horror movie I think
it 100 is oh I can go on and on about
this topic the original Terminator I
think is very scary uh it really scared
me when I was a kid and uh it it
affected me in that way where I was like
genuinely having nightmares about it and
I I think I think I had asked for a
Terminator 2 which probably would have
been more appropriate for a
five-year-old but my parents were like
oh Terminator one Terminator two same
thing so I got T1 so I saw a guy get his
heart ripped out in the first two
minutes and um yeah that really stayed
with me and but that made me want to get
into real horror movies let's say okay
and uh the ones that really stuck with
me alien Nightmare on Elm Street
Poltergeist and when I say that it
helped me with my americanness I mean
there's a component to American Horror
Cinema that there's so much iconography
cultural iconography even something like
you know Nightmare on Elm Street with
the I'm your boyfriend now Nancy you
know like there were these moments that
I had seen my friends talk about and
whatnot and I I would go and see these
films to try and understand and man
watching these things it was like okay I
think I have an obsession with with
these kinds of movies I will say I am a
big believer in in genre bending
sometimes I stop using the I don't use
the word hard deliberately because I
feel like many box it into a very
specific thing when it can be so much
more Beyond it so I think I think we
need to to reintroduce the idea that
horror can be a multitude of things and
you know I think that horror is such a
crucial part of a bigger umbrella of
American Cinema which is the American
Blockbuster right like you can't you
can't really talk about Jaws or Jurassic
Park without talking about
both horror films you know and both
affecting the audience in that way and I
think that's part of why we go see these
films in a mass audience I mean there's
nothing like screaming with an audience
okay here's my follow-up question and
kind of my my part one to that first
horror question so we know that that T1
is the first movie to scare you what
about the very first horror movie you
saw where like you had such a good time
being scared that you walked out saying
like I need more of that feeling in my
life I I can pinpoint exactly at the
moment it was I was 16 when the first
Conjuring film came out and but I'll
tell you this the hype around this film
was that there's no there's no violence
like there's no bloody violence there's
no language there's no sex but it's
still rated R because it's so scary and
the kids were daring each other to go
see them in high school right and I saw
it and I was so terrified and then I I
showed it to my parents that it they
couldn't make it through halfway and
there's this component of horror
filmmaking which is playing jokes on
people right playing a bit of a Rank and
I just loved they were yelling and they
were they were mad at me they were like
why would you do this to us and and I
think there's part of that prankster in
me that like really enjoyed that
experience and I was like I have to keep
seeing these things I have to keep
seeing how they affect an audience as
big of an audience as possible have your
parents watched your movie yet they have
they watch the whole thing they did
watch the whole thing and now um my dad
doesn't go in the basement anymore when
it's too dark uh but it's it's a dual
experience because while they're scared
this film in so many ways is so personal
and I think it meant a lot to them to
see you know these moments that are
really from our our life yeah and not
what not I respect his choice not to go
in the basement you have a couple of
very memorable elements in this that
ever since I watched it for the first
time like I can't stop thinking like
every time I see a jar I obviously I
think about it being like a containment
thing and then on top of that there's a
line in your movie about whistling and
I'm a big Whistler and now every single
time I Whistle I feel like I'm I'm
welcoming the evil in but you know
what's wonderful about you saying that
is that you know that was so much of
what was exciting about making an Indian
horror film right is bringing those
elements of our culture that we grew up
with these strange little superstitions
and and now kind of infecting the
American public and the international
public with these things I think that's
what's so great about horror films it in
a way culturally is that we're sharing
commonalities but we're also also
sharing these differences whistling we
just we don't like whistling there's
something there's a component to it but
now you have that too it's definitely
like bird its way into my brain I have
so many follow-ups to so many things you
said first just to start more broadly I
love asking this question because I love
hearing about how ideas evolve along the
way what is the biggest difference
between your very first draft of this
script and what we now see in the
finished feature you know I just re-read
the first draft just as a kind of
nostalgia trip a couple of weeks ago and
I was surprised by how much is still the
same I mean in the sense of the
foundation of the story what Sam goes
through the family Dynamics but you know
what what struck me and this was a
misconception I had before making this
movie is that there's no real final
draft of a script the final draft
happens when the movie goes to theaters
and people see it right
um but I was just so struck by how many
how how much more effective the film was
at telling its story a lot of that was
the rewriting process a lot of that was
the expertise of my partners at QC and
neon and uh it just is so much better at
it being itself than it was in its first
draft you know and I guess there's no
huge difference that I can think of
Beyond I think it's just so much more
effective and that was that's what like
was so inspiring about oh like this is
what collaboration is like when you have
people that really care about the story
you're just constantly making it better
and telling your own story better yeah
to get a little more specific with that
idea can you tell me about an especially
challenging day on set a time when
things weren't going to plan you had to
find a creative way to Pivot and you
wound up finding new magic that you had
never planned for that made the movie or
a particular scene maybe even stronger
one of the hardest days was uh and
you've seen the movie it's a moment
where our teenage characters go to like
a little bit of a quarry area with a
little Lake and they have a fun party
sequence it was very planned originally
and then you know weather issues came up
as they often do and um it became the
sort of thing where okay we have less
time for this than we thought
um I really leaned on my actors for that
the young actors in This film are
phenomenal Megan Suri plays that scene
so well and and you know I can just hold
a camera on her for so long and she
gives you so much uh intelligence and so
much emotional sort of nuance and
everything and then Gage Marsh is in
that scene too and the two of them it
was kind of like okay
well why don't you guys play with the
scene we had a very choreographed very
blocked out but in the end I so so much
more preferred the kind of uh loose
energy of of the camera kind of reacting
to what they were doing I think there's
much more nervousness in that scene
because of the lack of time because
these two actors it was kind of like
okay here are two cameras let's just see
what kind of happens let's see what you
how you two play off each other it was a
great lesson not to overstep as a
director and to really let the actors
kind of live in the energy of the scene
oh I wanted to go straight to a specific
scene with uh Megan where it's just like
absolutely perfect and it like if it's
not perfect it it kind of ruins the
audience's connection to the character
but I need to ask something else before
I get there specifically the the demon
that you chose here first was the was
the pishage like always like the first
choice for the evil entity in this movie
or did you ever consider anything else
it was always the first choice and I'll
tell you why there was um a lot of this
came from
my grandfather told this story right
that when he was a young man
that he went to a family friend's house
and his the friend's daughter had a jar
that she carried around and talked to
and one day he said you know there's
nothing in the jar right and and she
opened the lid angrily and threw
something at him but nothing came out
and so he's he goes home and then he
starts hearing weird noises in the
middle of the night he says he heard
galloping horses and then the big one
and this is you could see where the
movie came from but the big one is he
left a pack of peanuts out one night and
then he heard chewing and he turns
around and they're gone right so this is
a story I grew up hearing and uh it was
one of my favorite ghost stories that my
grandfather told but I was I remember
thinking to myself
what could that have been right and that
was the project of the movie that's
really where the inspiration came from
was what could that thing have been what
was affecting him and as I was reading
more and more there were other demons
but really you know making a movie about
teenagers and a teenage girl kind of
coming of age and finding her identity
as I was reading about the mythology of
the passage in in our cultural texts it
was like well there's no better monster
than this this thing feeds on mental
instability it feeds on loneliness and
it just felt right for the both the
concept of the film and the characters
so given that story you just told I'm
assuming the containment method was
always planned to be a jar it was always
planned to be a jar and I I love these
iconic things that can hang with us from
movies I love the scissors from us for
example and I really love when a film
has that you know and and I love when I
can pull Christine has the car that we
pulled you know the John Carpenter
Christine so I wanted one kind of icon
tonic piece of memorabilia in there now
you nailed it and like seeing Tamara
with the well I don't just like
everything about about her look and just
holding that jar and there's so many
moments where the way you frame her it's
it is like incredibly eerie but also
like strikingly beautiful at the same
time where I Can't Take My Eyes Off the
frame that makes me so happy to hear uh
do you know the story of Preston surge
has made a film called the bad day at
BlackRock right and the whole thing was
that the studio didn't want him to do
this in cinemascope because it was like
five people in the whole film because
they were saying oh you need cinemascope
for Cleopatra you need for Spartacus
when you have thousands of people in the
frame but his argument was that no sit
there's no better format for showing
loneliness than cinemascope because the
single person is so small in the wide
frame and that was a huge part of how
Matlin the DP and I kind of approached
the uh the framings of this movie and
there's the one where she's walking
through the rain it was always about how
lonely can can we make these characters
within this very wide cinemascope frame
you feel it so much all right so now
we've set up your evil entity and the
fact that it is contained in a jar so I
could ask about this next particular
scene it's a scene in the locker room
with Sam and Tamira when she knocks the
jar out of her hand because in that
moment like I understand sometimes
things things happen in the heat of a
moment you can't control yourself but by
Sam doing that and the audience already
knowing they're watching a horror movie
and knowing something bad will happen if
the jar breaks you run the risk of Sam
breaking the jar and then losing the
connection to the audience because the
audience gets mad at her so what was it
like having a conversation with your
actors in terms of finding the right
tone so that felt authentic in the
moment but you didn't lose that
necessary connection it's a pivotal
scene in the movie I'm so glad you
brought it up uh this is a great story
one of my Idols one of my favorite
directors saw the film and when that
moment happened he said oh no and it was
just like so gratifying for me so I'm so
glad that moment lands but you know it
was really something we were working on
to the end in the edit room we were were
playing with the levels of you know
distant whispering and all that because
it's all about Sam's Point of View I'm a
huge point of view person when I'm
thinking of how to shoot a scene how to
cut a scene
um that scene you're absolutely right if
we were always afraid that we lose the
audience to our main character loses the
audience 19 minutes into the film but
you know I think the the sort of
Storytelling challenge was establishing
this character with enough depth and
conveying enough of this very Universal
emotion this feeling of I want to fit in
but there's something in the room that
doesn't allow me to and the idea was if
we could use this kind of slower for a
stack to get the audience there with Sam
if we could understand her point of view
then we're getting into what is
ultimately the core of the Curse movie
right starting with the demon and all
the way to a huge film for me was Sam
Remy's Drag Me to Hell and it's the same
kind of element right is that you get to
know a character and then they commit a
transgression and then their first until
they can undo the transgression it's a
structurally brilliant sort of sub-genre
of the horror genre and so that was the
idea was she does have to do something
wrong for this
um for this curse to kind of come on her
but that we also don't lose the
understanding that you know as much as
we would like to say that we wouldn't
have maybe some of us would have also
done this in high school out of fear and
insecurity it's like authentically
fallible and like characters aren't
interesting if they don't make mistakes
and that's the idea with
um with this character Arc and certainly
every movie I want to do is that there
is something missing in the character
that we hopefully see in ourselves that
we have to be honest with ourselves and
say I think I dealt with this too you
know and I think that's why why we made
this movie ultimately because as much as
it is about the specificities of being
Indian American I mean I think who
doesn't know that feeling who hasn't
been there and felt small and different
yeah right that's what I mean it's one I
love horror but also all formats of
Storytelling because I find it easier to
process difficult human truths and maybe
my own faults via movies TV shows books
Etc rather than facing them head on
myself well and what I love about what
you just said I mean horror Cinema I I
think that every sort of a transgressive
taboo subject that's tackled in the
mainstream and a Prestige drama for
example I think 15 years ago has been
done in a horror film you know and I
think that the the reality is there are
certain experiences that to convey them
realistically you have to do them in a
horror film right and that's what was
the idea of this film is that what she's
feeling if I try to express that in a
very dramatic format in a kind of
straightforward Coming of Age film I
think we would be outside of that
emotion but doing it as a horror film
you don't feel the equal of the true
feeling exactly when you're when you're
in high school these feelings feel
massive right and they feel like they're
good it feels life-ending and for an
audience to really get that for an
audience to feel the film I mean the
fact that a you know modern American
Horror is really coming from German
expressionism right and expressionism
with Caligari and more now like that was
the whole idea was externalizing of
course the internal feelings and I'm
hopefully we're still doing those kinds
of films because they really mean
something to an audience first true
student of horror and it is really
exciting me right now your name dropping
all the right things before I have to
let you go I want to make sure to ask
about how the pashash attacks did you
always know that that the invisibility
angle was the way you were gonna go and
you know what was what was some of the
evolution in terms of the way you shot
those action scenes as you worked with
it and discovered the possibilities
there absolutely I mean that's one of
the rules that we do know from our
mythology is that it can be invisible
and that it can shape-shift and the
shape-shifting component we didn't do as
much with in this film because it didn't
end up like working with the tone we
were going for so much but the
invisibility angle it worked perfectly
for kind of how I want to make films and
I'm so uh constantly looking looking at
movies like Jaws or alien and I think
that leaving it in the audience's
imagination is so much scarier as as any
filmmaker worth their salt will tell you
um but in this case I just loved I loved
the idea of playing with the audience's
expectations and there's a psychological
component to the film but bringing the
audience in on what Sam and then Joyce
and uh you know the mother and the
father are going through where it's is
this real is this really going on am I
seeing things
um and my favorite sequence I think the
most effective sequence of horror in the
in the film is when uh Joyce is playing
issues in the bathroom she's playing
with the lights yeah you know that's a
real thing I have a laundry room that
has one of those light timers and every
time it goes off I'm convinced I'm gonna
die every single time I'm just so scared
uh but it's that it's that same kind of
very Primal feeling I think if you can't
see the thing but it lives in the
darkness and you have eyes staring out
which I think Rob Savage did wonderfully
in the boogeyman
um and it's just so so Primal I have to
end with this question because now I'm
just too curious what is your favorite
movie of all time that feels like a mean
question to like throw out like on the
spot but I have to know book one uh
I think the film that I've watched the
most and that is I think just seeped
itself into my mind is probably the
shining
um it's it's my desert island if I had
to teach all of filmmaking
um that I know at least which is very
little but that I know I think
everything's there in The Shining I'd
also say Hitchcock's notorious is
another one where it's like everything
is there
um but they're movies that really pull
you into a world and into the characters
and it's it's just those are movies I
could watch anytime any day for as long
as it's on TV I could talk to you all
day long about genre I wish we could
just keep you here but you have more
interviews to do so you can celebrate
your movie more and make sure the widest
possible audience is well aware of it it
lives inside huge congratulations thank
you so much first feature again
seriously you should be very proud do
not miss it go check it out